here's the thing I want
Oh God
we don't need these dumb instructions
these are useless what I'm kind of
worried about getting this I feel like
I'm gonna catch a hot one in the eye my
eye the guy used to see it like
Brookstone those like nose hair trimmers
yeah like I think that was like little
teeny little flashing this is boy looks
like compared to that is this more fun
than taking a shot yeah
is this more efficient than taking a
shot no yo this was at a party I believe
I am totally aghast what we do with
these first off if I'm having an ice
cream I don't want an apple it's a lot
of gutting things and then putting
things and other things get a bowl this
is for someone that's just trying to
make their life more difficult yeah you
have to be really dedicated if you want
to make Pinterest stuff for your party
Oh kill myself with this thing you know
how I said I hated this before I kind of
like it now because this one worked out
and I'm pretty proud of my
accomplishments man this is whack did
people struggle making these things cuz
we just knocked it and here's a buck
Walmart with the step attention to
detail Oh strawberry and lemon is
disgusting
why we didn't even put the masking tape
on it they've got like decorations and
stars and things on this we're gonna get
stars I'm here for moral support right
now
I thought Pinterest was much more about
like wedding dresses guys impress other
guys on the size of their grill yeah
girls impress other girls on the
cuteness of their Mellon would you
manhandling this we can't serve this at
the picnic you cannot pay me or you can
pay me to do this yeah it's gotta ask
you I'm a proud gay mama right now Oh
the more you know is that star yeah this
side I like that we crushed it I want to
almost take pictures of what we did and
put them on Pinterest is now for people
that want to cut corners people that
want to look cute I made chicken
parmesan out of cold pieces of chicken
and string cheese
I'd make a Pinterest about how to cut
the sleeves off your shirts you look
badass